what is a claim Trump is the greatest US
president in history Berlin is the
capital of Germany the government should
provide universal health care I'm
wearing white shoes these are all claims
a claim is a statement and claims assert
something something that could be true
or it could be false and often a claim
is a statement that needs to be proven
or supported and this is done through
the use of an argument which also
involves premises evidence and reasoning
but before even trying to determine
whether a claim is true or false it's
important to know what kind of claim
you're dealing with because claims can
fall under two categories descriptive
claims and normative claims a
descriptive claim says something about
what is or what could be descriptive
claims are objective impartial and don't
involve value judgments such and such is
the case for instance Fox News has a
website the trueness or falseness of
this descriptive claim can be determined
without invoking values go to Fox
news.com and there's the website on the
other hand a normative claim makes an
evaluation relative to something else
which means making a value judgment for
instance Fox News is awful this is a
normative claim because it involves a
value this claim relates to standards of
awfulness the claim can't stand on its
own without consideration for what it
means for something to be awful you can
think of descriptive claims as asserting
what is and normative claims as
asserting what ought to be let's look at
some other descriptive claims Tom only
eats ice cream Michel often doesn't stop
at stop signs Sarah is wearing a green
shirt these claims alone don't tell you
anything about my perspective on these
matters whether or not I feel that these
things are good or bad or how I think
these things might affect something else
but here are some normative claims a
about the same people Tom should rethink
his dietary habits Michael is a bad
driver Sarah should dress differently
before using a green screen these claims
use implicit inferences about how people
ought to behave in reference to other
values good driving good nutrition and
proper green-screen attire let's take my
claims about Sarah my descriptive claim
is Sarah is wearing a green shirt this
is objective and doesn't involve other
values but how do I know Sarah is
wearing a green shirt because I can see
her shirt and it's green but take my
normative claim Sarah should dress
differently before using a green screen
I'm making an assertion about what ought
to be
I'm implicitly referencing other values
that aren't present in my claim the
value of not blending in with the
background and the value of that being
preferable for reasons that are based on
other values like making a good video
for example understanding all of this
helps you understand how certain claims
might need to interact with other claims
not all claims can stand on their own
without being inextricably linked to
other ideas values and arguments that
need to come into play wrapping your
head around normative versus descriptive
claims can help you recognize bias in
yourself and in other people it can also
allow you to avoid trying to solve a
problem merely by describing its parts
or on the other hand prescribing
solutions to problems without properly
describing what the problem is and this
is a fundamental concept and beginning
to understand how different types of
claims need different types of
justifications this miniseries is made
possible in part by brilliant if you
want to become an even better critical
thinker you should check out this online
learning service brilliant is a site
where you can learn about logic
fallacies multi-level thinking and
countless other topics related to
philosophy mathematics and science
what sets brilliant apart is that you're
actually learning by working hands-on
with
life problems one of their principles is
effective learning is active and this
makes a lot of sense there's a ton you
can learn from passive activities
reading books watching online videos but
you're never really taking your
understanding to the next level and
applying what you're learning until
you're able to work with real-world
scenarios and that's what brilliant
allows you to do master anything from
probability to physics to the concepts
of artificial intelligence and
everything in between
sign up for free by going to brilliant
org slash critical thinking I've put a
link in the description under this video
and the first 200 people who visit that
URL will get 20% off an annual
membership visit brilliant org slash
critical thinking